[Music]
oh god sorry frank
sorry strong form
my name is dr lily houghton my brother
and i are looking for passage upriver
what's out there in the jungle it's not
a fun vacation well i'm not here for a
vacation
legend has it that there is a tree that
possesses unparalleled healing power it
will change medicine
forever and you need someone to help you
find it here we go
sometimes it just needs a bit of a
nobody touches my engine but me
what did i just there you go
we're gonna do this together haven't you
been dreaming about adventure
she was always chasing after some
far-fetched idea
everything that you see wants to kill
you and can
[Music]
do you want to turn back nope just
getting started
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
torpedo
so what are you doing out here
there is a legend in the jungles of the
amazon
of a tree that heals all it could change
the world
but if it gets into the wrong hands he
could awaken
a great evil i believe that the legend
is real
and i'm gonna find it just imagine the
lives that could be saved
i've been looking for this tree longer
than anybody
i've tracked a legend to every village
every island nothing
you're searching for something that
can't be found
but you've never had the key
let's do something that's safe let's go
see some elephants there are no
elephants in the amazon and i don't even
like elephants lady everybody likes
elephants
know this about the jungle everything
that you see
wants to kill you and can
careful they can smell fear i am not
afraid
oh my gosh who brings a submarine to the
amazon
[Applause]
[Music]
get it hold on come on i got it i don't
got it no no no no no no
just leave me alone that was a disaster
didn't go the way i planned
[Music]
legend has it there is a tree in the
amazon that possesses unparalleled
healing powers
and the arrowhead is the key to
unlocking it
hello uh just wanted you to know this
has been mislabeled
he's shipping outlets
of all the jungle cruises you can take
in the amazon this one is undoubtedly
the cheapest but also the most thrilling
heads up coming through
look out
marauders
natives
ladies and gentlemen the moment you've
all been waiting for
the backside of water
steve's wonder of the world
we're headed up river to lagrimas de
cristo let me secure our travel come on
hello not a good time my brother and i
are looking for passage up river
please go away i have a lot of money
if you believe in legends you should
believe in curses too
you're gonna beg me to turn back well i
look forward to disappointing you
10 000 to bring you there alive dead
it's 15 000.
why should i pay more dead
dead i'd have to carry you that's a lot
harder lady
here we go
oh sorry frank sorry strong form
i cannot swim you booked the river
cruise and you can't swim
the price just went up
[Music]
you